Of these options, the third one, the fourth one, and the sixth one are useful.
In the first one, the public key for Udacity is inside of the hash,
and so we have no way of actually getting that. So that's not useful.
For the second one, the encryption is done using Udacity's private key,
so this is a self-signed certificate, which is not very useful for us.
The fifth one is not useful, because the host name "udacity.commune" is not bound with the key.
We would need to include that in the inputs of the encryption.
The third and fourth ones are useful.
We have our host name. We have our public key.
Both of these are inside the encryption.
For the sixth option, this is is a certificate chain.
We have from the certificate authority the public key of trusty certs.
The trusty certs signs the public key of Udacity and binds it to udacity.com.